the weather is working against fire
crews battling multiple
wildfires in southern california where
temperatures are expected to
top 100 degrees today the so-called
ranch fire is
the most serious threat right now nearly
400 homes are under evacuation orders
about 20 miles
northeast of los angeles that fire and
two others in the region
have burned more than 20 square miles
jamie yukis is in
azusa near the ranch fire jamie good
morning
good morning the fire behind me is
called the ranch fire and firefighters
were concerned throughout the evening
that winds would pick up
they have been and what we've been
watching is an explosion of fire on that
hillside
firefighters right now are desperately
trying to cut a line
and save this bridge
the ranch fire burned into the night
thursday it exploded midafternoon
coming dangerously close to a
neighborhood of about a hundred
homes the issue we have here is not only
steep terrain but we have very very dry
brush vegetation when it's continuous
vegetation like that the fire just keeps
moving through it
it was a similar situation at the nearby
skyline fire in corona
the hot dry weather pushed flames near
homes
forcing evacuations that were lifted
late thursday night
i was looking and i was like is my house
going to be okay i was terrified
meanwhile firefighters worked overnight
to contain the lake fire some 70 miles
to the northwest in castaic
crews spent the day fighting back the
flames high
unpredictable winds made the battle that
much tougher
if this wind continues to change like
this that could change conditions and
might lead to more evacuations
officials say at least three structures
were lost but the final number
could be much higher it's just sad you
know
that my friends have lost their homes
the lake fire is five percent contained
but this ranch fire
is zero percent contained and there's no
estimate on when
either one of them will be put out by
the way we could be in for a long fire
season
the peak season starts this month but
can last
all the way through november anthony
jamie thank you
quite a scene behind jimmy